my mother sir Wayne jimana Oh like wah
hello everyone I'm JC I'm the creative
director on Far Cry primal and I'm here
today with max hi I'm creative director
at Ubisoft Toronto we're working in
partnership with Ubisoft Montreal on Far
Cry primal and today we're showcasing a
couple of the new features we've been
building for the game so what we saw at
the beginning of the video is actually
early on in the game
Allah is the budem war chief and this is
his tribe they're attacking your village
and so now we're trying to make our way
to their homeland in order to retaliate
and the occasion to start exploring the
majestic world of arose the Stone Age is
a time when man was not at the top of
the food chain and basically our
hirotaka will have to make its way from
the bottom to the top of this future
speaking of here's the mammoth I don't
think we're ready to hunt the mammoth
yet no we're not ready yet but there's a
few ways we can improve the situation
you see there's a dead goat on the
ground so that means there's a predator
nearby and in previous games uh
predators were only danger this time
around they are even more savage but
since the car is the beasts master he
can also use it as an opportunity so
he's able to tame all the wild predators
of Avalos so we have a wolf in front of
us let's try and tame it and then oh
there it is through the bait on the
ground yesterday that's gonna calm it
and then we're gonna tame it there you
go
so cool so now we have a beast we have a
direwolf it's an amazing beast and one
of the ways we can use it in the world
of velocities are through hunting and
tim is a super important part of your
experience in a Ross and it's a good way
of getting resources that you need for
your upgrade and send your beast is
super easy you just point send your
beast over to us at that time that's
open world my friend yep so everything
is just a major but we'll find another
prey something big here we find a yak so
yak is a big prey because these wolves
are diverse the huge themselves start
chasing she's got you by the tail the
throat
goodbye
perfect time for a reward maybe there
you go you can feed your beast it's also
the way of hitting done we just keep the
yeah it's your chance to get resources
from it which would enable us to upgrade
so let's see what we can upgrade there's
a lots of way of hunting traps placing
traps on the ground is also another way
of hunting in their primal because we
just killed a yak now the carcass might
attract that the Predators in the area
it's acting there's a dole that's coming
exactly so we're just gonna set the trap
on the ground and wait for the ball to
come so this is a great opportunity here
to get resources there's a lot of way of
hunting different animals in the game
and once you manage to get the harder
resources you can upgrade a lot of the
aspects of the game there's a weapons
bags etc so tons of and locks for you
here we can take a look at the world map
of arras the world is really big and
it's in fog the fog of war so you have
to travel the world in order to invoke
it there's no more radio tower because
of a Stone Age but what you see here is
a bonfire a bonfires are used to fast
travel everywhere to the world above us
and it's also a place where you can
access your village - so let's go there
and claim it for ourselves
oh the wolf is growling so all the
animals have abilities and the wolf will
grow in order to alert you of a nearby
enemy you can use one of the other tools
of the beast master in order to recon
the environment around you the car can
summon the owl to be able to fly around
survey the area get a good tactical view
you know we've marked three enemies so
this one the one with the orange horn is
able to summon reinforcements so it's
probably a good idea to go in more
stealth and so will summon another one
of the animals which is the Jaguar which
is a very good for stealth approach yeah
exactly what's fun with the Jaguar is
that if you crouch it's also gonna go
although it's gonna be stealth that make
much noise not attract
any enemies are predators so let's take
out this first guy headshot so here's
here as long as we crouched and the the
Jaguar is crouching it's completely
ended and detectable and so we can
approach very steady from the enemies oh
that was a good headshot this is exactly
what I love to do when I played a game
send my beast on a first target and take
out the second one right away and then
double take down and so now we can claim
the gunfire over the fire rope so this
is really cool because it gives us a
very important anchor point in the world
where we can fast travel it maybe just
conquer the world of a rose and have
much more ease as we travel sweet but
there's a lot of other ways we can have
we can travel through the world of a
rose as the beastmaster you can summon
now you can give order to a beast but
you can also ride a wide array of
animals like the young mammoth but you
also have other beasts that you can
write and it gives you a really a lot of
ease as you travel through the world and
you're able to move much faster but also
use it as a weapon there's a good
opportunity so you can see the green gas
which is one of the weapon of the Sudan
and a rhino just decided to run away
so here we see the glacier of Oz in the
back we'll just skip ahead to the
outpost where we'll find a lot more
resistance and will summon a saber-tooth
what a great feeling I love doing that
for the saber-tooth is one of the
deadliest predators in the in the game
world and once you have one at your side
it gives you a lot of power so we've
arrived to the outpost that we're hoping
to attack and the best way or the best
course of action is to summon
trusty owl and weaken the area exactly
when flying with the owl the different
icons tell us the types of enemies that
we're gonna be facing there's a lot of
things we can do with our it's not only
a recon tool we can still give orders to
our beasts so we could command it from
here but we can also drop different
types of bombs
let's do that let's set this outpost on
fire with some fire bombs here we go and
we can also use it to attack enemy dive
down directly to invisible so this of
course is a rating average so now our
they are looking for us
that's it's time to assault because here
spear to the head send us a retreat
Oh jump attack I love that one thanks
super cool and take down and then throw
us off to another dude
about the double do it there we go huh
reinforcements that's not good to be
much a source so we let's summon one of
the biggest tank in the game to Cape air
which is a very resilient can take a lot
of punishment individual portunity to go
round the enemies
so on some personally which is another
one of the cool toys of the Beastmaster
agents especially with the bees
is there any yes perfect that from above
the birds IP there you go
yeah there was just a small taste of the
amazing Stone Age open world full of
surprises and danger that we've got
waiting for you thank you very much DC
Thank You max see you soon
you